study finds 87 of chinese takeout eaten
by team prosecutors embroiled in
late-night investigations
i love that trope it's so funny that you
know whether it is prosecutors or
corporate lawyers they're all in front
of a big table late into the night and
then they just get box after box of
chinese takeout and they have some
brilliant idea while shoving lo mein
into their mouth the onion is by far the
best source of satirical news on the
internet and they have on occasion taken
shots at the legal profession but the
best satire has a grain of truth so
let's see
how the onion does when they make legal
headlines
alright so right off the bat
jurisprudence fetishist gets off on a
technicality
that's sick
probably something twisted like smj
uh oh my god i can't believe i just made
a subject matter jurisdiction
bdsm joke that is uh that is a heck of a
way to start this video amazing
uh katanji brown jackson weighs history
against soul-crushing thought of
spending time with these people ooh okay
i really think that the thought that the
members of the supreme court are
not friends with each other or at least
professional with each other i think
that's completely overblown i think
despite their political differences i
think probably most of the people on the
supreme court are perfectly fine with
each other and the people on the supreme
court are perfectly fine human beings uh
i don't think uh katanji brown jackson
uh will have much of a decision to make
here she's gonna make history
all right uh class action suit against
god pays out 45 extra seconds of life to
every creature
oh that hits close to the home
especially given the number of class
action suits i've i've covered calling
it a historic victory for all who have
been victims of the lord's negligence
lawyers representing the planet's
estimated 20 quintillion animal
inhabitants announced tuesday that a
class-action lawsuit against god would
pay out an extra 45 seconds of life to
each creature lead attorney landon burke
announced that anyone who believed they
were owed restitution by god could reply
to the notice they received in the mail
or sign up online to receive their
supplemental 45 seconds of life
that's really funny because that is
often how you have to provide the class
the restitution that they get is through
a postcard it's a whole thing in federal
court or going to this really janky
website that always looks like a scam
why do the class action websites always
look terrible
people don't sign up because they think
that they're being scammed when often
it's it's legit i mean class action
lawsuits are notorious for paying out
really small amounts of money or coupons
to the class often the only people who
get rich are the class action lawyers so
actually in this case this is brilliant
if
you actually were a plaintiff's attorney
and you got 45 seconds of life for 20
quintillion animals then effectively
year 30 or 40 of that quintillion
animal seconds times 45 seconds they'd
live forever
it's always the plaintiff's attorneys
who get
tons and tons of money even if the class
gets almost nothing
plaintiff's attorneys man
supreme court rules gay rights do not
extend to dessert
that's
uh i mean that's that's too close to
what actually happened while homosexuals
do have the right to get married the
right to equal treatment does not cover
instances of pastry cake or candy all
right so
uh
the the supreme court case in question
is a little more nuanced than that but i
get where they're coming from on this
one
all right man who never missed alan
mcbeal back in the day joining the trump
legal team
oh boy it seems like uh it seems like
only yesterday that we were dealing with
donald trump and his team of horrible
horrible lawyers
honestly if you were comparing rudy
giuliani and sydney powell to someone
who never missed an episode of ally
mcbeal
i think that would be a fair fight that
would probably be fine and the funniest
thing about this article is that it's
from 2018 the worst trump lawyers hadn't
even been retained at that point
man we were so innocent back then
christ sues catholic church for
unlicensed use of his image
i never signed off on nor do i endorse
the sentiments behind any of these
candles plates statues paintings none of
it i don't want to have my brand
devalued by a bunch of people just
trying to turn a quick buck by slapping
on a reproduction of my wounded body on
a cross
oh
boy yeah i mean frankly uh i'm not sure
a whole bunch of people want to be
associated with the catholic church
after
all of the headlines that have been in
the news over the last couple of years
yeah
especially jesus but at the same time
this is kind of similar to that little
nasex
issue where he made the satan shoes and
he also made the heaven shoes which was
a whole thing with nike and they didn't
want their brand associated with it so
uh i don't know i guess nike is jesus in
this particular scenario i'm gonna have
to figure that one out that's
interesting
uh new uber update allows users to file
a lawsuit against the company directly
in the app oh
no that's too true
oh god
i wonder if those lawsuits have quieted
down i haven't heard much about uber
getting sued these days i mean there's
the whole thing in california where it's
a question of are they misclassifying
employees as independent contractors but
i mean back in the day
uber had like
6 000 assault allegations made against
them and they they actually funded a a
recovery fund of four or five million
dollars
i
god i hope that hasn't continued to this
day but man
you know having a button to be able to
sue uber within his own app that would
uh that probably be helpful hopefully
they have now cleaned up their act and
uh that's no longer an issue but it was
it was kind of bad back in the day
law school applications increase upon
realization that any [ __ ] idiot can
be a lawyer
oh boy yeah i mean in the wake of the
really crazy kraken lawsuits it really
did
seem like anyone could be a lawyer it
goes to show you once you pass the bar
it's really really hard to take
someone's bar license away though
i gotta say they sort of proved the
impossible in that a lot of them got
sanctioned and some of them were
suspended we'll see what happens to rudy
giuliani he may in fact lose his law
license seemingly doing the impossible
we always knew he could do it
study finds 87 of chinese takeout eaten
by team prosecutors embroiled in late
night investigations
i love that trope it's so funny that you
know whether it is prosecutors or
corporate lawyers they're all in front
of a big table late into the night and
then they just get box after box of
chinese takeout and they have some
brilliant idea while shoving lo mein
into their mouths it's such a great tv
trope i hope it never dies because it's
it's amazing
speaking of which everyone on defense
team an equally matched romantic
interest remember prosecution
this is this is such a great uh trope
that of course like everyone on the
defense team has their counterpart on
the prosecution and they're gonna fall
in love and uh they will betray their
client for the greater good such a
wonderful trope
american bar association recalls 230 000
defective lawyers boo
boo i say
though in fairness there's probably way
more than 230 000 defective lawyers
that's how many new lawyers i think are
created or at least how many law
students uh there are in the country at
any given time so
there's probably a lot more than 230 000
defective lawyers
i hate to be the one to say it none that
i've ever worked with the lawyers who
have been members of my firms have all
been outstanding and have not been
defective in any way shape or form it's
it's always opposing counsel that's the
defective one your honor i am jet you
would now whether you are a lawyer or
just want to think like one you can make
sure you're not defective with logic or
math with a course from today's sponsor
brilliant brilliant is an online
learning platform for stem that replaces
lecture videos with hands-on interactive
lessons brilliant is for curious
learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced and one of my favorite
courses is all about logic brilliance
logic courses cover liar and
truth-teller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day and
brilliant lets you learn by doing rather
than listening to hours of boring
lectures learning through doing is
scientifically proven to be the most
effective way to master any new skill
the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve and within brilliance library
you'll find courses and topics like
calculus linear algebra and math
that apply to trading and finance you'll
also find courses on gravitational
physics astronomy and machine learning
and you can level up in just five
minutes a day by working on the daily
challenge each daily challenge provides
you with the context and framework that
you need to complete it so you don't
have to take a deep dive if you don't
want to no need to make your brain bleed
now you can sign up and start learning
today for free at brilliant.org legal
eagle and the first 200 people to sign
up will also get 20 off their annual
subscription so just click on the link
that's on screen right now or in the
description to get 20 off your
subscription to brilliant plus clicking
that link really helps out this channel
and while you're there click on this
link with all my other legal videos so
click on this link or i'll see you in
court